uh Welcome to our committee
and I would also like to welcome the
colleagues from the committee on
development
in the hearing of today the Latin
American region will be appraised from
different perspectives by our free
expert speakers and then the flow will
be opened of course for members for qat
a the aim of this hearing is also to
prepare our upcoming visit of the effort
committee to Chile and Brazil at the end
of June
I don't have to tell colleagues fat
Latin America and the EU share common
values culture and also a mutual
interest to strengthen our political
relations and cooperation further
the upcoming Summit in July this year
represents an opportunity to explore
possibilities how to engage more with
our partners in Latin America and the
Caribbean bilaterally and also an
international forum
we represent one third of the United
Nations votes we are particularly
grateful for the nearly unanimous
condemnation by the states of Latin
American Caribbean in the Caribbean of
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine in the United Nations General
Assembly
we are interested to hear about the
geopolitics of the region against the
backroom of the Russian wall of
aggression against Ukraine internal
dynamics of the region and for
influences by other Global actors
I would like to warmly welcome our free
expert speakers
Professor Jose Antonio
director of the Carolina Foundation then
Professor benedicte Bull from the center
for development and the environment from
the University of Oslo
and finally Mr Oscar Guinea Iman yes
senior Economist at the European Center
for international political economy
I have been informed that the agreement
is that we give you the floor each for
10 minutes
and we kick off with you Professor
please
oh before I forgot I would like to
welcome of course Mr Latin America Chevy
Lopez who chairs for delegation
after this
well good afternoon it's a pleasure and
a privilege to be here thank you for the
invitation the relationship between the
European Union and Latin America and the
Caribbean is characterized today by a
twin paragost on the one hand it's one
of the regions which exists where we
have a considerable tradition of
political dialogue of racial and
economic links but since 2015 these
relations have stalled on the one hand
this is a second paragost we should be
asking ourselves how is it possible that
we have this stencil when both regions
are together are facing an international
system in which crises are building up
and which demand changes in our
development and external policy
strategies so just a note on this
tradition which certainly this chamber
is aware of in 2024 we have the 50th
anniversary of European Latin American
political dialogue which didn't start
between governments but between members
of parliament in July 1974 the first
palatino and European Parliament
Conference was held generated by
International politics
to face military dictatorships and the
violations of human rights at this time
10 years that later the government
stepped in with the San Jose dialogue
and the subsequent EU Rio group dialogue
supporting the peace processes of
contador and esquibulus and the
democratic transition and consolidation
and since the 90s to generate a trade
and investment at this stage and the
decisive role that this apartment took
place that leaves us a legacy of
elements which are becoming relevant
again and this relationship should
served to widen the autonomous region
margins of both regions faced with the
attempt to raise a new bipolarity the
important regionalism and Regional
integration and its contribution to
multilateralism cooperation of
development cooperation with political
objectives with democracy as a backdrop
per piece and also combating inequality
areas which have a little economic or
technocratical technocratic significance
but uh political geopolitical
significance in international agreements
the association agreements were
diversification strategy in our
relations and protected trade flows and
the investment faced in the ftta and the
small ftaas small versions of small
scale which the EU signed with countries
and specific groups just as today we're
faced with economic competition and
technological competition between China
and these countries another Legacy
inter-regionalism between EU and Latin
America which can respond to some of
these tough uh foreign policy interests
and balance of power interest the
diversification of relation and access
to Market but also its expression the
standardized version and we know the
regional groups are as building our
building components of global governance
based on the affinitive ideas and shared
values in this context uh biracial
political dialogue between the EU and
egg black has been interact accepted
since 2015 and this is something which
is of concern it is because of the
political uh fractures which America
Latin America has gone through and the
lack of attention which has been paid by
Europe into regionalism requires a
minimum of cohesion and agency
and this means that Regional groups have
to be involved this minimum have given
rise to political fractures between the
bolivarian group and the conservative
and right governments and the response
of these Master to act like and unicell
which is also very ideologically this
was key in the decision of uh
government that Brazil will be
absolutely would date would withdraw
from ekla the pandemic and demonstrated
the depth of the crisis in Regional
organizations in the withdrawal of
Mexico and Brazil traditional Regional
ladies leaders all this can be reduced
to the capacity of the region to act
faced with the pandemic or The Invasion
if you create in both cases Regional
agreement neither existed nor was
expected also a cooperation with the EU
is stored due to the erroneous idea that
most of the countries countries that had
to be graduate graduated as recipients
of Aid and the commercial preferences
the GSP commercial negotiations run
their course but this agreement in
Bristol between eel and Microsoft June
2019 was not to move forward due to the
European rejection and the dire
Environmental Policy of the government
of higher personnel and Brazil and the
reappearance of protectionist insects in
the EU at any time the lack of political
dialogue between the EU and Eclair
assumes a cost but the costs are greater
now the International System was going
through a stage of crisis of
globalization in the international order
was faced with an abstinent Corporation
and it's not an option the pandemic of
coven and the war in Ukraine call for
both regions to make changes in their
policies and their International the
link so although this impact may be
different the pandemic and the war in
Ukraine exposed the vulnerability of
both regions faced with the Health
crisis under the eruption of uh the
geopolitical eruption of the supply
chains now submitted to a logic of uh
security and the risk of weaponization
the development strategies are being
securitized giving priority to security
and resilience at the expense of
efficiency this is the case of the
United States in the European Union in
Next Generation EU repo EU combined
objective social objectives productive
sustainability and also security
objective that in America after the
pandemic is faced with disruption Supply
disruption and high inflation rate with
a fiscal space which has been reduced
and greater debt furthermore it is an
angry a region of angry societies with
high levels of discontent it is as
infection in democracy and political
problems all this calls for rationality
and for a new objective of the
relationship between the EU and Latin
America and the Caribbean it's necessary
to have a new and renewed narrative
position and a new negative I propose
three uh main ideas firstly
relationships have to be extended
together to enlarge the autonomy of both
regions faced with a growing
geopolitical rivalry in the world but
this needs governance rules and
certainty on this question the EU is
discussing strategic autonomy and Latin
America is discussing issues between for
this relating to the search for regional
autonomy and active non-alignment these
are convergent agendas and they don't
imply defensive withdrawal but they
imply the construction of associations
between reliable allies that extend
their room for maneuver at the same time
reinforce Global governance secondly
this Association
contributes to strengthening democracy
and open societies the same one in both
regions we are seeing a major disc
consent among our citizens that arising
illiberal of authoritarian and extreme
right forces it's not just a question of
uh electoral processes of political
Liberties and the rule of law but also
of attacking the regions for
disaffection
and the expectations of progress which
are not happening
states which don't guarantee a minimum
of security for their citizens segmented
societies through equality cannot be
accepted for this so we have talk of
democracy and dis and development at the
same time we have to talk about renewal
of the social contract thirdly the by
Regional relationship should be should
Define novel partnership strategies
economic and Commercial and new types of
cooperation to relaunch development
after the pandemic with a triple
transition triple social transition
digital green and social have to be just
transitions uh and if they're not just
they won't be transitions at all I'd
just like to look at the first of these
three regions because the others will be
tackled by my colleagues it's important
to to remember when between 2020 and
2023 a window of opportunity was opened
perhaps a single one to achieve this
although it also pose new risks which
can cause obstacles the return of Brazil
to eclac is a very promising stage in
Latin American regionalism a very
positive factor the economic
complementarities between both regions
and the war in Ukraine uh
highlighted this but can also help and
there's more political will to make
progress to resume the dialogue and
establish political links which are
stronger between America Latin America
and the EU is today an imperative to
promote strategical economy of both
regions faced with a double risk uh
remain trapped by the crisis of
globalization and for the geopolitical
competition between the US and China to
start from this scenario is a major risk
of systemic conflict as is illustrated
by the war in Ukraine and the growing
tension in the China Sea uh as uh
president macron recently pointed out a
great tension around the issue of Taiwan
Taiwan for Europe and for Latin America
will be a great economic not just a
political problem a new cold war is not
in the interest either Latin America nor
the United Nations United United the EU
but it puts them in a position of
strategic subordination they question
their utility and withdraw as a junior
subordinate actors it's a discouraging a
compromise between the institutions and
reasonable multilateral standards and
cooperation International cooperation a
warning at the uh attitude of
schadenfreude which sometimes you see in
Latin America the rise of China is
undeniable but uh
uh it uh occurs because it weakens the
EU as part of the western uh a part of
the collective West after uh Latin
America's uh and Latin America can bear
the cost also it cuts down on its
autonomy and its room for maneuver in
its capacity to meet Global challenges
with this in mind uh less Europe also
means less America less Latin America
furthermore this uh Narrative of
strategic competence
um
is strongly uh focused on security it
changes the agenda democracy human
rights gender equality the environment
economic cohesion social and territorial
cohesion sustainable Global sustainable
development means there are importance
of the July 2023 Brent Brussels Summit
the limits of political dialogue will be
in part marked by the differences in the
Garen and the war in Ukraine both
regions uh coincide essentially The
Invasion is a violation of the
provisions of the UN Charter on the
prohibition of the use of force it's an
act of aggression he will violates basic
principles such as the sovereignty and
territory of uh uh integrity and not
interventions not acceptable to have a
war of Conquest to redraw borders
precise Latin America which I believe uh
which believes in some of these
principles which are fully integrated
into international law for these reasons
America doesn't accept Latin America
doesn't accept nor will accept sanctions
which are not been adopted by the United
Nations in principle and because of the
economic costs which they assume and the
name of neutrality some countries have
rejected the requests of European
leaders to transfer arms and ammunition
to Ukraine the EU should not continue
insisting on uh the alignment with Latin
America relying on arms or on sanctions
also it's not appropriate to put the war
in Ukraine within the access of
democracy versus authoritarianism as the
United States has done but within the
Constitution constitutive principles of
international law to which we all share
there are voices both on the extreme
right also and parts of the left of the
region which assume The Narrative of
Russia and China which is that NATO is
responsible for the invasion and they
question the military support which has
been given to Ukraine and which is there
for it to exercise its right to
legitimate defense they want to avoid
being militarily overwhelmed which is
going to mean that they end up with a
piece of the losers partly this is
something which responds to the
Anti-Imperialist tradition of the left
wing in the region but also the
influence of media such as RT and
Sputnik which in Latin America present
themselves as alternative and
Progressive channels so this question is
necessary with this question we need
more dialogue and more political
education by Europe the EU should be
demanding faced with facts which uh
such as those which led to the visit to
Brazil of Russian Minister lavrov Lulu
is partly aligned with the Russian
narrative on the origin of the war and
uh believes that Ukraine is
co-responsible for The Invasion and uh
that military aid from the EU in the
United States would extend the war
Brazil really doesn't have a real peace
plan and probably uh it was so aware of
the fact that the E of the of what the
EU is do that there are no conditions
for a negotiation at the moment as the
Secretary General of the United Nations
had already said with its proposal
Brazil contradicts its own position in
the United States and it has weakened
its aspirations to be a mediator by
defining beforehand questions on the
possible return of Crimea of Crimea as a
counterbock to peace I think it's
incredible to see that we could have a
meditation mediation between a more
broader strategy of the bricks and China
and that in the piece uh that in in
bringing peace to Ukraine at the
nevertheless Brazil
and other Latin American countries can
make a contribution important
contribution to a fair piece in in
Ukraine if the conditions are right
which will require an imaginations an
attitudes of listening and talking and
also staying for some of these possible
scenarios at the end of the year in
Ukraine uh it could be more favorable to
negotiation on the basis of which the EU
could and most European countries assume
this via their voter and the United
Nations and I think that in the long
term if we Bear all this in mind we
shall be more able to reconstruct uh the
country on the base of the European
security architecture thank you
thank you for your first presentation
and immediately nag of the floor to
Professor benedictable from Oslo please
thank you very much Mr chairman
chairman distinguished
thank you thank you very much Mr
chairman of the committee and
distinguished Europe parliamentarians
it's a great honor for me to be here
especially as a fortune unfortunately a
non-member
uh my intervention will take the state
same starting point as that of my
colleague
um Professor sanah that due to his vast
natural resources that Latin America is
of key importance in the global green
transformation Latin America also has
ambitions of playing a role in the
shaping of a new Global Order we hear
many similar Concepts as those that we
discuss here in Europe in order to frame
that role active non-alignment as
mentioned is one intelligent autonomy is
another
this signals to be a desire to be
independent of great powers and to have
a place in global politics this should
be embraced by Europe and corporations
should be focused on how to include
Latin America in a global Endeavor to
pursue Democratic social and green
transformation
however this of course faces many
challenges and I've been asked to to
talk about some of the internal
challenges as well as external
influences
Latin America does not speak with one
voice it has highly different countries
and Regional cooperation is weak
unfortunately Regional Corporation in
Latin America has had a tendency to
depend on government's identification on
the same side in a left right spectrum
and thus when Gabriel borage was elected
in Chile Gustavo Petro in Colombia and
not least Lula da Silva in Brazil some
observers started to speak of new left
wave that could sustain stronger
Regional coordination and cooperation
the successful Summit of the community
of Latin American and Caribbean state in
Buenos Aires in January was a promising
sign of unity however there are major
hurdles to overcome one major challenge
is the relative weakness of most
democratic countries in the region
leaving limited leeway to engage
seriously in demanding foreign policy
Endeavors over time
the reasons are multifold but the signs
are very clear one is the already
mentioned deep distressed in any
government this has resulted in the
punishment vote a tendency to reject the
government in power no matter its color
uh while the re-election of Precedence
used to be the rule in Latin America if
able to run it's now the exception we
saw one exception in in Paraguay in the
John April elections but I don't think
there will be many more only in overly
authoritarian countries including
Venezuela Nicaragua and most likely El
Salvador in 2024 presidents are
re-elected also many many current
leftist governments may fall prey to the
punishment vote Argentina might be the
next case
this distrust in government also leads
to a shortening of honeymoons for new
governments less than a year after the
celebration of the victory approval
ratings for Pedro and borage fell to
less than 30 percent Ecuador and Peru
are in the midst of seemingly endless
governance crisis with interrupted
precedencies again presidents with clear
authoritarian traits harassing opponents
and the media and weakening institutions
unfortunately fare better that includes
bukele in El Salvador
in
Costa Rica
this is partly a result of the general
discontent in the population due to
Rising crime rising cost of living
persistent corruption and inequality
crime has not increased across Latin
America there are some cases where
things have improved but certain areas
have experienced dramatic upsurges
notably Ecuador and Chile are
experiencing hitherto unseen levels of
violence in both countries this is
partly due to a re a shifting pattern of
international organized crime both with
the including changes in the cocaine
trade with more shipments to Europe and
uh and and and the upsurge of human
trafficking and extortion across borders
a main backdrop is of course also the
covid-19 crisis still poverty remains
far above covid-19 pre-covet 19 levels
in Latin America and it may increase due
to inflation
the inflow of Venezuelan migrants in
most countries has added to this it has
now reached 7.3 million around 20
percent of the original population and
in spite of a modest economic
Improvement into 2022 in Venezuela
outbound migration continues
while Venezuelans overall have been well
received there are exceptions and moods
are changing partly due to the parallel
expansion of Venezuelan criminal
organizations such as the the infamous
trendar agua it has also created border
fictions various places
in many countries populist politicians
are able to exploit the generalized
discontent
it's important to Define populism I use
it as a political strategy that exploits
divisions in the population through a
mannequin and anti-elitius rhetoric and
establishes a direct link between the
leader and the masses based on his or
her Supreme representation of the people
across the regions candidates exploiting
such strategies have emerged
we should remember that many populists
also fail bolsonaro Was Defeated so was
Rolo Fernandez in Colombia nevertheless
populists contribute to weakening
democracies through attacking
institutions and spreading distrust
the same is true for some external
powers in Latin America notably China
and Russia China now what what have what
I would call structural power in Latin
America it is the most important trading
partner for South America it is an
important lender and an increasingly
sophisticated and diverse investor
there is a broad consensus in Latin
America of the desirability of being
associated with with China mostly for
economic reasons and that includes
businessmen on the right as well as
activists on the far left there is very
little desire to decouple or even
de-risk from China
thus
China often don't even need to State its
opinions clearly to be taken into
account still Chinese officials react if
someone openly criticized them in this
sense China often doesn't practice its
non-intervention Doctrine and has the
potential for closing Democratic spaces
while China has structural power Russia
had has what may be called sharp power
as also alluded to by sanahuja it is
able to pierce penetrate and perforate
the political and information
environment in Latin America the main
instruments are the cable networks erity
and espanol and the News agencies both
make news as well as of course social
media for Russian Elites Latin America
is mainly interesting due to its
strategic proximity to the United States
in addition to being markets for arms
and fertilizers but Russian sharp power
has evident influence on The Narrative
of world events spreading in Latin
America whether about the crisis in
Venezuela the Democratic breakdown in
Nicaragua or the Russian invasion of
Ukraine it perforates the regional
consensus and important issues this may
fragment the region reduce trust in the
governments and hinder Regional
cooperation
taken together all of these factors
reduce Latin America's Unity given that
how should Europe and the EU relate to
Latin America
you must make sure that its agenda
appeals to Latin Americans and not only
responds to EU priorities I sometimes
hear in Latin America that European
Europe has eucronized it has become too
focused on its own security challenges
and problems fortunately EU also
prioritizes a green transformation
however focusing on that we must not
pretend that the green shift would will
benefit everyone equally or that it can
respond to everyone's needs to be
successful in Latin America a green
shift must be backed by strong
institutions and there must be a
compensation for the losers that
includes state coffers of course but
also poor Central Americans fleeing due
to climate change rural dwellers facing
encroachment on their lands and
resources due to extraction of Rare
Minerals or Urban poor faced with cuts
in fossils subsidized subsidies one way
to do so is to support Latin America in
its effort to climb up the value chain
and avoid getting stuck again in a role
as a commodity producer fortunately
despite the general distrust of
government most Latin Americans still
believe in democracy while the EU lacks
China's structural power and Russia's
Shore power it still enjoys significant
soft power as a defender of democracy
and human rights EU should appreciate
this and not try to force its way in
Latin America as the U.S occasionally
does to counter China's influence rather
it should appreciate Latin America's
diversity as well as its desire to have
a place at the global table it should
partner with Latin America on topics of
importance to Latin America and that and
that pose deep threats to their
institutions including Global Drug
reform and support for democracy
particularly words most threatened which
is in Central America
with such an approach the EU can become
a positive external force and help Latin
America navigate and participate in a
new Global order thank you
thank you Professor bull
and now we come to our third and final
speaker Mr kinia
ibaneza thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you very much for the invitation
to speak at the committee in my
intervention I'm going to talk about the
institution and infrastructure that the
EU in Latin America require to deepen
the economic and political relations
with a focus on the EU Chile the EU
Mexico and the EU medical student
agreement
free trade agreements are no longer
about import tariffs the tariffs pays by
the EU and Mexican exporters
said for chile it was 0.1 percent and in
the case of mercosul which are known for
having a higher common external tariffs
the average trade weighted import Duty
was six percent
for some of the most politically
sensitive Goods like sojour minerals the
simple Duties are 0 or close to zero
so what are free trade agreements about
if they are not about importance free
trade agreements are mostly about
non-tariff barriers non-tariff barriers
are behind the Border regulations that
restrict International Commerce
so a big chunk of the effort made by
negotiators inflated agreements is
devoted to Regulatory harmonizations and
rules that facilitate trade and reduce
uncertainty for Traders and investors
rules for what
for agricultural products that's for
sure but agricultural products only
progress
now we've heard what organelle said uh
um said much about our relationship with
marker sir uh what do you think about
this protocol what do you think this is
going to move forward an additional
protocol that's been said could be at
least uh outlined by the salac EU Summit
but that seems a bit optimistic to my
mind possible but optimistic we see the
reluctance of some member states uh
those are well known as reluctance of
some member states and then this affects
our relations with Brazil and Argentina
finally
we've heard you about to talk about the
shared values well I would hope that
this Summit between EU and select would
make a clearer statement in the past
when it comes to the Russian aggression
the Russian aggression is not something
that just affects uh Europe no it's an
international uh matter it has uh it is
called to question the most fundamental
rights
and I think this is something that needs
to be in the statements coming from the
summit but it seems that uh we should
not just uh have empty words
I mean the Santo Domingo conference
basically did that the wording on the uh
the court there was left much to be
desired thank you
thank you
Xavi Gonzalez
Chevy Lopez
yes well thank you yes
well first of all uh I'd like to thank
you for having organized this audience I
think the presentations were very good
very useful insightful and I think the
timing is great something that is good
but also very necessary this
relationship between Europe and Latin
America and looking what's been said by
others the fact that we've got this year
of a calendar a number of different
events different elements the Strategic
importance of this and also the context
of the war is also sharpened Minds here
the Spanish presidency the uh the the
summit between the EU and selac and then
the finalization of the outstanding
agreements which have been in the
pipeline now for a number of years
uh where this is maybe the maybe you
know the the Train the last chance to
get on this train but I'd like to put
three questions in this context first of
all
the geopolitical reality in which we
find ourselves and the relationship
between the EU and Latin America well I
think it's pretty important to see the
role played by Brazil in this area
and uh
and then also then the brick grouping
which includes Brazil
also sometimes put Argentina they might
go into that club too well not really
I mean it was seen that the region likes
the South South cooperation not
necessarily to the detriment of
cooperation with the EU but that then
brings on South Africa and China and uh
and other similar countries including
then also with Russia
which then does go into a competition
with the EU that's a possibility that
that is part of the the mindset of the
bricks and uh and then maputan has a
role to play potentially there yeah
we've also got the international courts
front so so where are the are our
openings here
how can we build a stronger relationship
between the EU and the region with this
in mind when you've got the bricks and
competition now the second question
what do we want and what can we hope
from this Summit the EU select Summit
there might not be quite the same thing
what we want and what we can actually
achieve we've got the Gateway initiative
we've got the different areas which
we're preparing on our side for this
Summit but we might also think about
what we really would like to achieve and
what we're likely to achieve the third
question
this has to do with Association
agreements what we what was said about
the importance of these Association
agreements was very insightful their
added value uh the the preconceptions
which are exist
so how come it's so difficult
why is it so tough to finalize these
Association agreements I mean they
they've got the protectionism at the end
of the day
uh there's always just new things coming
to the fore new problems are are being
detected uh
and uh again what's holding this up
thank you
thank you so much
yes well thank you thank you very much
to the speakers well today if today
we're discussing Latin America I mean
lots of reasons because I mean we've got
Spain that soon is going to be taking up
the presidency of the council in just a
few days well I think it's a very timely
that we're discussing this and we also
might mention what Spain hopes to
achieve but if we think about this it's
been a number of years since we really
had a clear strategy for this region
we're still waiting for the publication
of The Proposal from the CCR
so and then we've got the international
order which is being challenged here in
the European Union and elsewhere and we
don't know sometimes who actually shares
our values in this the rule of law and a
rule-based system we've seen that there
is a lack of of a strategy to develop
this we see this lack of political will
often that's holding up the
formalization of our agreements with
Chile with Mexico uh and I won't even
say anything about America sir but we've
got Uruguay and other countries of the
region who are signing agreements of a
new generation than like the Chile
now we look at it we need a strategy
which takes out these different facets
so I would call upon our speakers today
to tell us what they think about these
new areas that I think are key but which
are not exclusive first of all the
defense of the liberal International
world order I think it's very concerning
that we see this hybrid position of
Brazil when it comes to the definition
of rules in this context we see this and
that would come to the fore with the war
in Ukraine and then also it's a tight
links with it China with became and we
need to have a clear economic stretch
strategy with this area with Mercer and
the bilateral agreement should be
basically the key with our new
relationship and our new relationship
with Latin America it should be win-win
at the present time we're really not
achieving our potential in this region
and then finally the state of the rule
of law and human rights well as Burrell
said and it will typically in these days
in Havana to call
when Sanchez to uh to uh
basically stop with his the efforts in
Latin America there so I would call up
on the EAS to actually have a full
chapter on the uh violation of human
rights in the cube by the Cuban
opposition of the or by the government
rather against the opposition and the
release of the thousands of political
prisoners in Cuba
and right then also we've had a good
friend uh who has been and arrested now
for two years in Cuba with a no contact
Beyond his own family uh once a week
he's allowed to see his family and
and uh
moving on to Nicaragua well I must say
something about that country I'm just
appalled by the situation there and
really we should be active there with
that dictator as well Bolivia while some
are still afraid to say what's true here
but Olivia there are political prisoners
and there is persecution of the
opposition and uh and and and you have
to ask anyas I mean if you want to ask
him he's in jail right now the former
president
why because the dictator the president
who has unilodally decided with his
structures of power in place and in the
courts to keep the former president in
prison uh Fernando Camacho won't say
anything about them we also needed to
support that person then Venezuela last
on my list we should try and
promote proper uh negotiations when
Madero allows for proper elections
everything else is pretty much to not to
be on the table
we're being asked every day that there
have been authorization of this uh
process we need to do this not just in
Venezuela but in all those cities all
those places where people should have
their right to to vote to respect it
and finally liberal principles
investment uh between the two regions
and uh the institution building and the
defense of democracy so that's uh I just
sum it up in a word
it's in what it boils down to is
political will to achieve this
thank you Jordy Sully please
thank you chair the first thing that I'd
like to do is thank you and congratulate
you on your speeches because you've all
done very interesting analyzes of the
issue so I would like to congratulate
you on your initial remarks I would like
to agree as well
that there is a need to
build a more stable permanent and
strategic relationship between the
European Union and Latin America and the
Caribbean
it hasn't been that way up until now and
I think that there are circumstances
that may lead us to believe that we're
moving in this direction
in the near future and why must we do
this because we share values we have
common
challenges to face we have a clear
economic uh complementarities the
complementary aspects uh on an on a
social and political level as well we
all want to move towards a green
transition for geopolitical reasons as
well I believe that both blocks
don't want to be stuck in this growing
geopolitical rivalry between the US and
China although that doesn't mean that we
want to be
equidistant but we do want to
remain independent more I'll bear in
mind what you mentioned about how some
Latin American countries find China
increasingly attractive
because of what China can offer
we want
cooperation among equals of course
that's clear but it's also clear that we
are talking about an asymmetrical
relationship we have a European block a
European Union on the one hand that has
a certain
weight
political coherency although I would
like this to be even deeper and on the
Latin American side this has already
been said
there is a weak Regional cooperation a
lack of integration there are
democratic governance issues there are
very clearly authoritarian regimes
and those authoritarian leaning
democracy so it is a an asymmetrical
relationship because only lather
reconside there are more differences and
divergences but that being said
I think that to renew this relationship
we need to change the paradigm
we must
think Beyond trade deals economic deals
and envisage other dimensions for
instance human rights protection
Democratic support this should be at the
heart of any policy that we want to
develop the fight against climate change
how we can use our soft power as a
European Union to support human rights
Defenders indigenous communities
persons who are being persecuted
and how we can focus
cooperation on fields that are very
promising the digital field the equality
policies education and involves Civil
Society in this much more than has been
done thus far
and also we need to
be much better aligned with our internal
actions as European union and our
external actions what we're doing inside
of the union we want to be able to
translate this to our external actions
and finally chair I wanted to find out
from the speakers what are the
perspectives for regional integration in
Latin America I know it's a complex
issue
there's a great deal of sub-regional
Corporation we've talked about divisions
on the continent as well what role could
selac play
what
could the dynamic look like in years to
come thank you
thank you we have three more speakers
according to my list Mr matu Miss
Gonzalez and Mr
oliveiras did I miss anyone
right Mr matu
thank you very much to the speakers for
their presence and for the interesting
explanations that they've given I would
like to welcome what I understand to be
a new or renewed uh commitment to this
Latin American policy because
this region unfortunately has not been
on the eu's radar for the last few years
and that is shown clearly by the time
that has passed between the last EU
Summit which took place in 2015 and now
I understand that this is a very
transcendental moment it's a key moment
and we must take advantage of it we've
got a fundamental goal which is to
strengthen relations in decades to come
to build a strategic Alliance
because let's not fool ourselves we both
need this and we've got a great deal of
uh difficulty we've got any challenges
to fit together the next Summit
um must
have the necessary content for the
alliance to be understood by citizens
and for them to have more opportunities
there are many paths to accomplish this
first of all in 2023
we this is the year of agreements
intensification of relations with Latin
America this has to pass through the
ratification of uh agreements with um
Mexico and Chile
and there is this sensation of weakness
which undermines our credibility
and
there is a bit of a timidness that is
preventing us from moving forward this
space that we leave behind is being
occupied by countries like Russia and
China they'll continue to do this and
strengthen their presence in Latin
America
we've also heard a mention of other
elements of cooperation global gateway
the digital
partnership for sustainable development
or uh security I would like to emphasize
one thing which is that in the next
euclac Summit we need to pay attention
to the protection of Human Rights and
the strengthening of democracy and the
rule of law in Latin America by no means
must this uh Summit serve to whitewash
authoritarian regimes we are growing
increasingly used to human rights
violations in countries like Nicaragua
and Venezuela but there are also issues
in other countries that are of concern
and so I hope in the next joint
communication on the new agenda for uh
relations between the EU Latin America
and the Caribbean
uh this comes forth and a message that
this
commitment is a commitment by all of us
some of the countries in the European
Union like Spain and Portugal are more
used to this but the other countries
must join and understand the
geostrategic importance of this region
thank you
thank you Gabrielle Miss Gonzalez please
thank you chair and thank you all the
speaker I will continue on in Spanish
gracias Professor thank you Professor
we will follow your reportery keenly and
we've talked about uh moving from a
relationship of a friendship to a more
strategic relationship what I would like
to focus on is development
because I work in the diva committee and
so in light of the report of the UN on
trade and development from April where
there has been a mention of the fact
that the global economy will suffer in
the post-pandemic period and because of
debt and the lack of liquidity the
situation is going to hit developing
countries hard particularly Latin
American
um mid-income middle-income countries
where there is high inequality as we're
all aware so I would like to ask
Professor Sanu including a special
rights for
transfers as a source of financing to
support middle-income countries and
promote development projects that
strengthen economic independence of
these countries and improve the quality
of life experts say that
the new uh special rights can be a first
step to alleviate the debt burden of
these Latin American countries
this burden that makes uh development so
difficult so with this barrier that
we're now facing I'd like to know your
opinion on the possibility to use
these transfer rights for development
problems and financial entities so that
they can begin to consider these special
rights as a way to finance projects in
Latin America and my second question is
what expectations
do you as experts have on the
global gateway
project this roadmap for Latin America
that should be so beneficial but in this
Parliament we are wondering if it's
really going to lead to anything new and
when we say anything new are we going to
um we're going to
promote vaccinations and nothing in
America what monitoring is going to be
done green energy what are the projects
that are underway
um what are the tangible realities there
thank you
thank you and finally Mr cuminioli Perez
thanks presidents
I would also like to begin by
congratulating the three speakers I will
speak in Spanish your presentations were
very useful and I would like to focus on
something that uh colleagues have also
mentioned and that's a relationship
between
trade relations and geopolitical uh
leaning is uh The Narrative of Brazil
when it comes to the war in Ukraine is
very close to the Chinese narrative at
least and we're beginning to see
patterns uh there might be
more patterns when it comes to the view
towards Europe and let's understand that
this
relationship between Brazil and China is
both geopolitical and Commercial and
over 20 years the trade exchanges
between these two countries have
increased and in the same period we
began the EU mercosur agreement
negotiations and so let's be realistic
it is clear that our geopolitical
position is also dependent whether we
like it or not we like to think about
these things separately but we must
recognize that
they are closely linked to trade
relations and so it's not surprising
that Brazil is moving closer to China on
a political level so
we've already seen this and learned this
lesson it's crucial that the EU mercosur
agreement be finalized there is some
Latin American work to be done but we've
got a significant responsibility on the
European side and there needs to be
explicit reference and I don't want to
um
point out any country in particular but
let's take France
and Francis perspective on the crisis in
Ukraine it's the country that is most
obsessed with European autonomy as
regards the U.S and our transatlantic
relationship and we've got a specific
position as a European Union when it
comes to the crisis in Ukraine and the
relationship with Putin and that is the
country that it turns out is blocking
the EU Mercury agreement the most that
is a contradiction it's a flagrant
contradiction with all due respect to
our French neighbors it makes no sense
not finalizing this trade agreement and
we must also be able to rebuild if we
want autonomy and our bilateral
relations with the us we need to think
about this relationship as a triangle
transatlantic relations are not just
about relations between uh the US and
Latin America because there are benefits
for Europe and Latin America we need a
relationship with the US I'm wrapping up
now but it's clear that if we make a
triangle the risk of undermining uh uh
our interests will be lower so I just
want to agree with the general position
let us please once and for all wrap up
this EU mercosur trade agreement and
take advantage of the great opportunity
of the global great way to do what null
is asking for
um which is industrializing the
countries so that they be they can be
less dependent on raw materials thank
you
thank you colleagues for your
contributions we now have roughly 20-25
minutes left I would suggest that
our free guest speakers now have the
impossible challenge of trying to answer
as many questions as possible in seven
minutes each
and if you agree we will now start in
the Reversed order
so that gives you the big up
opportunity to pick the easy questions
and then it gets more difficult to the
end so you get the rest
your first well thank you very much I
wasn't expected to go first but uh let's
do it
gonna
so there was one of the questions was
about
um the risk of not
grabbing this opportunity with both
hands because otherwise there's going to
be a change or there will be a change in
the next parliamentary elections
European parliamentary elections and
where we will be on our relationships
with Latin America
on the size of the free trade agreements
I totally agree
about the importance of moving these
agreements forward in this lecture in
this legislative term
but I think the also the question kind
of is is the symptom of the fact that
our relations with Latin America lacked
structure
they lack an agenda that can winstand
change in Parliament that had kind of a
longer term that because
you know it's been so long since it's
been an EU select Summit that just the
fact that we have Summit is seen as a
success
when I would say that this should be an
ongoing relationship with agendas that
are built over time and we shouldn't be
surprised as we are not surprised that
the EU has a summit with the ancient
Regent
but that was the first point
the second question was pretty difficult
what I expect about the protocol
and and how is the protocol going to
look like
I don't know but if I will be able to
you know less Oscar I give you a
protocol write it
I will actually do two things
the first one the first thing I will do
is I will recognize that the EU has
passed a number of autonomous measures
on the deforestation initiative due
diligence forced labor
um what else
um c-ban which are really important and
it has really changed uh the
relationship between the EU and the rest
of the world
and I will acknowledge that in the
protocol in a way
because that really has it takes the
Steam and the pressure out of the EU
Mercury agreement to deliver on
sustainability Clauses on this on these
sustainability goals why because we
already did it the EU has put those
regulations some might like them or the
stoned but they have put those
regulations they will be part of their
key and it will be obligatory it will be
mandatory for any trade partner who
wants to export to the EU being from
mercosur from Indonesia from China
that's it
and the second thing I will do in such a
protocol will be to recognize the
contribution of the Latin American
countries or to sorry the contribution
of Mexico to climate change and
biodiversity
these countries have made commitments we
not in post those commitments to them
they have taken on the challenge and
they are doing quite a lot of things
that we you know if you take for
instance the amount of land that is
devoted to low carbon agriculture in
Brazil is the same space as Spain
you know Brazil is a big country but
that is not peanuts these countries are
actually making the effort and they're
making commitments by themselves and I
think we should recognize this and the
contributions to democracy as well and I
think starting from that kind of Level
Playing Fields from that con from from
the fact that we have an autonomous
measures and they have contribute it
takes his team out of the of the
sustainability Clauses and it helps move
on the discussion towards more
supporting our Microsoft partners and
businesses in order to implement the
the the regulation that we have imposed
and it kind of changed the dialogue into
something more positive
and so and in a way that's connected to
to your point about which is also a much
more difficult question how do you pass
the how will you how how can what can we
do to pass the agreement
and I think in a way
we should kind of think about this
agreement as being able to achieve
things that we may not you know take it
into account the autonomous measures
this agreement could also contribute to
sustainability in to kind of achieve
sustainable goals in Latin America in
America so sorry again
and and he can he can deliver that he
can be a sustainable development a
sustainable agreement and he can help
also the EU the carbonize some of its
sectors and it can also help mercosul to
industrialize
and the Strategic raw materials that
have been mentioned is an example of
that so the EU Imports more strategic
role materials from Brazil than it does
from China
the Rebellion volume
and with the Strategic Partnerships and
the Strategic projects we have a tool
also to contribute to adding value to
Brazilians not just mining but also
refining of strategical materials that
also help us to reduce our dependency
from China and fulfill our climate
change digital and their energy
transition
so in a way rebranding disagreements to
its you know achieving the goals that
all these people might be might not be
able to respect about these agreements
but they can actually do contribute
towards uh I think that will be that
will be a start thanks
thank you Professor bull please
thank you okay so I'll pick a few uh one
is Venezuela it was raised uh in the
context of the importance of of making
uh the commitment to free and fair
elections uh a prerequisite for for
dialogue I think uh the EU has a really
important role to play and to to come
back to the Venezuela process with full
force because it it has uh the uh the
steam in the dialogue has been lost a
little bit over the last uh last month
there was an achievement just last week
when the EU the United States finally uh
finalized uh the establishment of the
humanitarian fund that was agreed this
fall as a part of a dialogue but there
is a tendency now that
um this the dialogue process it
diminishes in importance while the the
interests in in re-establishing
relations to with Venezuela increases
and also the interest in in with in
reactivating the oil production of
Venezuela and that is a risk in terms of
uh democracy in Venezuela now I think uh
I think it is important to restate that
important that the EU comes back it used
to have a commission to to work on
Venezuela
um but at least that the U.S back
because currently the negotiations are
increasingly between the United States
and Venezuela with very few other actors
with any real clout the president of
Colombia Gustavo Pedro had a summit last
month to try to get the Latin American
countries on board but we haven't really
seen many results of that
um what can the EU really bring into
this what could what should we expect
and Hope from the from the summit I
think the EU has uh some uh particular
tasks and some particular features I
would uh emphasize uh the importance of
civil society and human rights and the
eu's experience uh with working with
civil society and not only government
governments as really important I think
we will see in the years to come
increasing conflicts over natural
resources over uh and and other issues
with Chinese actors primarily Russian
actors are not really that important in
in Latin America
um and uh and a demand for increased
attention to how to include Civil
Society both in agreements and and in in
projects and that should be a major
feature of what the EU is doing I also
think it's important to not although I
agree that the the Microsoft agreement
is important uh that is not the entire
Latin America and the success should not
be only be measured on whether that
agreement is passed or not there are
other countries other regions and I
would also urge that the EU continues
its important work in Central America
that currently is at Major risk of
falling into authoritarianism and it
really needs a strong International
partner
regarding the different organizations
it is very difficult to be very
optimistic on behalf of Select or unasur
these days although
Brazil has proposed the reactivation of
unasor there's talks that
the soon former president of Argentina
Alberto Fernandez will be offered the
position as as the general secretary but
it's very difficult to see that and
there is also other other attended sort
of there are some forces that try to put
Regional cooperation in the center of
foreign policy
um
so so the picture is not completely
Bleak but there are so many internal
conflicts and so many uh presidents and
and governments in Latin America that
have to focus too much on internal uh
internal issues one one example is
Gabriel chinchilla uh focusing on uh lat
on Latin America was actually uh
proposed as a part of the new
Constitution that was voted down last
year uh and uh we know it is a desire to
strengthen it but uh the political space
for us it's still limited I would say
um regarding Ukraine
um we have perhaps presented a very
um a sort of gloomy picture on uh on the
Latin America's relations to Ukraine I
think it's important to or sort of their
position uh regarding Russia's invasion
of Ukraine and we have listened to Lula
over the last uh year
um and that gives a lot of room for
discomfort but I think it's important to
emphasize that Latin America is more
than Brazil and also that there is a lot
of room for dialogue it is not a fixed
position also not in Brazil we've heard
many different uh statements by Lula and
by his advisors and I think there is
significant room for dialogue and I I
would very much agree with salahoka that
it is important to emphasize the aspect
of international law because Latin
America has been a pioneer of
international law and it's praised
itself of its of bringing almost all
internal conflicts in Latin America are
resolved through legal measures and
that is a that is a very important
principle to uphold also in in order to
open for a dialogue with different
actors on the issue of Ukraine
um
finally if you uh allow me I would just
make one reflection uh final reflection
and that is I think it is important that
the
um The Summit in July is not a summit
between Spain and Latin America there's
only been uh Spanish interventions there
and and we know of course that Spain
will have the uh the presidency and uh I
think all other countries should
appreciate Spain's effort to push this
agenda but it is important also the
other countries come on board thank you
to conclude professor
thank you I'll try to be brief and
answer all of the questions in an
integrated way the first questions were
on the ways that we have rediscovered a
lot in America with the war in Ukraine
and it's important for us to avoid this
idea that Latin America is El Dorado and
that we're as you're as European uh
as your opinion and are only interested
in them when it's uh related to raw
materials we need to have mutual
recognition that both regions need
a new industrial model a transition to a
different model and we don't want to
enter and
extractivist cycle once again China's
already in the cycle we believe that we
can
combine our need for
raw materials with their needs for
energy for instance one of the other
elements that has
made it possible to modernize the
agreement between the EU and Chile have
been concessions
on the EU side when it comes to lithium
exports to help
develop the supply chain in Chile so
perhaps this is the type of element that
could also help the EU Marco agreement
and also public procurement processes in
our relations with Brazil because it's a
bit contradictory that we demand
liberalization policy
of mercury countries when we are
rethinking this in Europe when we talk
about industrial policy we are thinking
about using public procurement to
promote Innovation here in Europe and we
are changing our development pattern uh
from what it was like a few years ago so
a partnership agreements were designed
in the 90s in a very different context
from what we are facing and now they
must not only be seen or mainly be seen
as free trade
agreements uh they are extraordinarily
important right now on a political level
and what and if what we want is to
recognize the political importance and
use these as instruments to move forward
with the Strategic partnership well then
perhaps we should be a bit more flexible
on both sides when it comes to some of
the Clauses contained in those treated
treaties which are outdated I'm not
talking about reopening negotiations of
course but maybe changing some key
Provisions like what we've already done
in the case of Chile and that might help
uh the agreement to be finalized we've
also talked about the split the
additional instrument and we want to see
if these additions on the table can help
move us towards this important agreement
then we've mentioned another instrument
at global gateway and it's an
extraordinary instrument we've been
asking for it for a long time it
responds to development
needs the region has a financing Gap
that's enormous and
we also have a geopolitical vision
here as well but we need to calibrate
global gateway well because it was
designed for enough for other regions
and we have to adapt it to Latin America
if investment gets to Latin America it
will not be because global gateway
exists we've all been investing for a
long time but we need to think about
what we can
add
investment in the green transition and
renewable energy fine but one of the
difficulties is when it comes to
investment in Latin America is soft
infrastructure it's hard to talk about a
digital transition when there are such
uh problems with the education system in
the region and so we also need to
include investment in the social sector
and in education one of the things that
we say to businesses when it comes to
difficulty to difficulties in
investments in Latin America right now
is that there are regulatory uh like so
this is not the old debate that we used
to have in fact in many cases companies
are there because
apart from the security problems
I'm sorry I got a bit too enthusiastic
so what we need and this is an important
component of global gateway and our
relationship we need a dialogue and uh
agreement on regulatory issues there is
enormous uncertainty when it comes to
regulatory standards that will exist in
many sensitive sectors when it comes to
the environment we for instance have
a an EU taxonomy that we are trying to
adapt to Latin American countries with
great difficulty but they already have a
structure for their
um ngos when it comes to global gateway
investment we need to have a discussion
on regulatory standards so that there is
not just a new wave of barriers that
will make uh it harder for us to move
forward with what with the ground that
we have gained
we also need to be realistic there is a
great risk of over promising
and then not be being able to concretize
our promises and we must not confuse our
cooperation with North America with
global gateway there are essential
elements of our cooperation for instance
when it comes to democracy and human
rights we have to defend the public
space when it we have to defend a human
rights but that is not going to be
discussed in this Summit because the
intergovernmental uh sphere makes it
difficult to talk about this type of
issue but this Parliament and the
commission
has tools outside of intergovernmental
dialogue to strengthen our influence
when it comes to defensive human rights
free
um media the Civic space
all of these crucial elements for
democracy and finally
what can be expected of the summit well
there's one thing that I expect of
communication
hi
an integrated approach when it comes to
EU action towards Latin America we don't
want to end up on one side trade the
external Action Service and all of these
operating separately we want it to be
understood that apart from the detail
the Clauses of the technical agreement
so
there is a geopolitical dimension that
must be contemplated so we need a much
more integrated approach of our
EU action we must not work in silos so
I've gone beyond my time thank you very
much for your attention
all right thank you very much
colleague said there are no further
comments from your side that the
thank our free guest speakers for
attending today's
session I thought that was a very
interesting exchange of views and uh
hopefully give some good input
for our work on strengthening the
relations with Latin American countries
our committee will be traveling to
Chilean Brazil
um soon and some of our colleagues will
be there together with me
thank you very much and I all wish you
now a wonderful evening
and the meeting for today is closed and
we continue our session tomorrow